depuis sa création en 2010 le service
civique a attiré plus de 260 mille
jeunes volontaires pour continuer sur
cette lancée et faciliter les rencontres
entre recruteurs et volontaire le réseau
évident information jeunesse leur a
donné rendez vous pour un speed dating
du service civique
on a un grand nombre d'adhérents qui
nous sollicitent pour réaliser plein de
projets on n'est pas toujours assez
nombreux et justement le recrutement
aujourd'hui d'un service civique nous
permettrait de réaliser au mieux nos
missions collectivités ou associations
au total 22 structures se sont déplacés
pour proposer une centaine de missions
un dispositif apprécié par les jeunes
qui voudraient même le voir davantage
développés où on peut poser des
questions c'est plus rapide et puis on
voit déjà l'enthousiasmé des personnes
également donc ça peut des fois motivé
plutôt que regarder sur le site internet
où là c'est vraiment
du texte mérite ça que c'est dommage que
ça n'ait pas été assez développée au
niveau de la partie
européenne et internationale plus
particulièrement n'a pas assez
d'association à ce niveau là en fait le
service civique peut durer de 6 mois 1
an et s'adresse à tous les jeunes entre
16 et 25 ans le tout est d'avoir du
temps libre et de la motivation pour
s'investir au minimum 25 heures par
semaine les jeunes qui s'investissent en
mission de service civique dans leur
parcours en fait ils sont à un stade où
ils se cherchent et wii peuvent
s'investir et donc c'est effectivement
les jeunes qui sont le plus éloignés de
l'emploi qui sont éventuellement aussi
sortis du système scolaire et pour qui
le service civique est un formidable
tremplin
reste désormais à poser les bonnes
questions pour trouver sa mission idéal
chaque jeune ne peut réaliser qu'un seul
service civique au cours de sa vie